one of the reasons that are that's most
cited as to a as to a cause or the cause
of why world war one turned into a world
war as opposed to just a regional
conflict in southeast europe is the
alliance system that was developing in
the decades leading up to world war one
and to understand that i've distilled a
bunch of the alliances that occurred in
those decades leading up to world war
one this is just a distilled version
there were many other alliances that
were tangentially related but i try to
distill down the ones that were directly
related to all of the dominoes falling
at in 1914 that led to all of europe
being essentially at war with each other
so to understand that we have to rewind
75 years so world war one is starts in
1914 75 years before that in 1839 you
have the treaty of london and the treaty
of london did many things but article 7
is what's what's relevant to the
beginning of world war one where britain
agrees to protect the neutrality of
belgium
and if you're skeptical you might say
hey this is a 75 year old treaty why
does this matter anymore and that
actually would be a good question
really all of these alliances it's a
very healthy debate you can have as to
whether these are the direct causes of
of why one of these powers declared war
on the other or whether these were just
excuses these were kind of a legal
pretext for saying oh i need to declare
war on you when in reality they really
did want to declare war for a whole set
of reasons to kind of keep the other
person's empire in check to flex their
military muscle to go after more
territory in their empires who knows
what it might be but needless to say
1839 was the legal basis for the british
empire to protect to protect
belgium
now you forward fast forward 40 years
you get to 1879 you have a a newly born
german empire out of the franco-prussian
war in 1871 that newly born german
empire they just had a essentially it's
it's an extension of prussia the the
fundamentally a german kingdom they just
had a war with france they took some
very valuable territory from france
they're paranoid that france wants to
get back at them they're paranoid about
their paranoid about the russians so and
they have some connection with the
austrians on the austral the
austro-hungarians i should say and so in
seven in 1879 they signed the dual
alliance treaty between germany and
austria
to protect each other if russia attacks
they have this common enemy right over
here russia so they're gonna let me do
this in a different color
they're going to protect each other so
this makes the new the new german empire
feel a little bit better about its
position in europe in case they were to
get into a war with either of these
characters
then in 1892 you could imagine if you
ever play a game of risk or if you play
the game of diplomacy which is actually
based on what happened in world war one
if you see some people that you might be
at war with starting to become friends
you want to look for other friends other
alliances that you can form in case they
declare war on you so in 1892 you have
an alliance between the french and the
russians the franco-russian military
convention so this is an alliance let me
do this in a let me do this in the
magenta color again you have an alliance
between france
france
and russia
and then finally in the early 1900s
1904-1907 you have a series of
agreements on essentially means
agreements agreements between the
british empire and france between the
british empire and the russian empire
to essentially get on good terms with
each other these weren't as formally
bonding that hey if someone's going to
attack you i'm going to attack them but
they were essentially able to resolve a
lot of their issues on what's going on
in their their other imperial conquest
and they formed what is called the
triple anton the triple agreement
between
britain between the british empire and
right here i just circled the united
kingdom france
france and russia and on the other side
of that you had the triple alliance you
have germany you have austria-hungary
and you also have you also have italy
now the reason why even though entering
into world war one italy was formerly
part of the triple alliance and there
were treaties between italy and germany
to become part of this triple alliance
the reason i don't focus on those is
once the war started italy did not go on
the side of german and austria germany
and austria-hungary
it went on the side of the allies on the
side of the triple and tante but this
will give you a good background for why
uh what would seem like a a regional
skirmish in in southeast europe uh turns
into a pan-europe and eventually
pan-global war